la des escalada y va progresando incluso
se ha afirmado que podría ser uno de los
primeros lugares del planeta en alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño pero el
resurgimiento de los casos de kobe 19 en
manaos la ciudad más grande de la
amazonas brasileño ha puesto en alerta a
las autoridades
un análisis internacional liderado por
investigadores de la universidad de sao
paulo indica que entre el 44 y el 66% de
la población contrajo el virus entre
mediados de mayo y agosto la cantidad de
pacientes colapso al sistema
hospitalario y los cementerios no daban
abasto sin embargo con el pasar de las
semanas las muertes disminuyeron de 60
decesos diarios en abril pasaron a sólo
dos o tres al final de agosto y la
situación se fue normalizando de a pocos
no obstante los números han vuelto a
aumentar es por ello que desde el
viernes las autoridades locales
decidieron cerrar playas y bares
prohibir reuniones y restringir las
horas de funcionamiento de restaurantes
y tiendas durante 30 días
el gobierno debe tomarse esto en serio y
hablar con la verdad decir lo que está
pasando y lo que no por dos razones
si dicen que no hay problema no
recibiremos ayuda si dice que no hay
problema eso impulsará a las personas a
ignorar nuestros decretos
las autoridades han indicado que los
contrarios se han incrementado entre
personas jóvenes que asisten a lugares
públicos y desarrollan síntomas leves
sin embargo ellos contagian a familiares
mayores que a menudo terminan bajo
tratamiento hospitalario